from countless sequels and remakes to
original indie horror 2024 Cinema has a
lot in store these are just a few of the
movies bound to blow audiences away the
horror genre has had a lot of success in
recent years turning short films into
big screen hits and their creators into
big Hollywood names come 2024 blumhouse
will try to find success with another
short film with the release of night swi
a featurelength horror movie adapted
from a short of the same name originally
produced in 2014 the short was written
by Bryce Maguire and directed by Maguire
alongside rod blackhurst and it was
snatched up by James Juan's production
company Atomic monster to be turned into
what's hoped to be the next big horror
hit this time though the roles are
reversed with blackhurst and Maguire
Penning the screenplay for the film and
Maguire alone sitting in the director's
chair the film concerns a family moving
into a new home complete with a backyard
pool one that happens to be haunted the
film stars Oscar nominee Carrie Condon
Rising Superstar Wyatt Russell and Nancy
Lenahan originally slated for a late
January theatrical drop the release date
was later bumped up to January 5th
The Beekeeper units director David a
with action Superstar Jason St had
finished filming in December 2022 with a
script from Kurt Wimer the cast is
rounded out by mini driver Jeremy Irons
Josh Hutcherson and Felicia Rashad stay
them stars is Mr Clay a retired soldier
who has settled into a quiet life in the
countryside but when the only person he
cares about kills herself after losing
all her money to scammers he goes on a
blood soaked mission of Revenge do you
know what they do here scamming the
weakest in our society buddy I'm counted
three 1 two
right what his enemies don't realize
however is that Mr Clay is actually a
member of a paramilitary organization
known as the beekeepers which unites the
most dangerous operatives in the world
in the process of Revenge he'll go up
against any number of dangerous enemies
and take on global corruption that goes
to the highest levels The Beekeeper will
set a high bar for action movies for
2024 when it hits theaters on January
12th singer songwriter James Samuel who
goes by the bullets has made a name for
himself in Hollywood coming to attention
in 2013 with his Western film they die
by Dawn and his 2021 Western the harder
they fall in 2024 he's back again with
the book of Clarence and this time he's
turning from westerns and telling a
fictional biblical epic AI Stanfield who
played Gunslinger Cherokee bill and the
harder they fall will star as the
titular Jerusalem native Clarence who
plans to take advantage of Jesus Christ
emergence as a religious figure despite
the spiritual nature of the story
deadline is reported that the movie is
not faith-based as for the all-star cast
The Book of Clarance will feature
Benedict Cumberbatch David O Yello James
McAvoy Omar Sai s Moen and Alfre
Woodard among others like his two after
mentioned efforts Samuel writes directs
and composes the score for the book of
Clarence which is being produced by
James Lasser tendo neenda and Jay-Z the
film was recently posted to January 12th
2024 from its original September 2023
release date originally scheduled for a
2023 Premiere the action comedy lift has
recently been pushed back to a January
2024 release on Netflix helmed by
Straight Out of Compton director F Gary
gray it's a heist film that stars a
bunch of big names led by Kevin Hart
supporting him are Vincent denafo gugu
andat Jean Renault Jacob batalon Sam
Worthington Bill Magnuson and Spanish
actress Ursula corbero in the upcoming
movie Hart plays a skilled Thief who's
dragged into a new job by the FBI
alongside his ex-girlfriend and a team
recruited from around the world he must
carry out a daring Heist of $100 million
in gold while aboard a passenger jet on
route to Switzerland the film is written
by Daniel kka The Man Behind the 2009
John Cena action thriller 12 rounds and
is produced by the Batman director Matt
Reeves in Simon kinberg Lyft will arrive
on Netflix on January 12th guys isn't
this so
fun clearly they're just super excited
probably just texting all their friends
in 2004 Tina Fay had her first post SNL
hit with Mean Girls a black comedy about
a group of feuding High School teens
based on a 2002 book titled queen bees
and wannab bees it was a huge hit and
even spawned a breakout success on
Broadway Mean Girls to musical in 2024
Fay will bring that musical to the big
screen written once again by Fay and
produced by SNL Creator Lauren Michaels
this time the principal cast will be led
by angori rice with BB wood and avantica
vapu or Renee rap will reprise her role
as Regina George from the 2020 version
of the stage musical Bay and Tim Meadows
will also return to play their original
characters who skipped out on the 2011
TV sequel Jenna Fisher bsy Phillips and
John Ham will also appear on a song
filed remake of the original Ashley Park
who stared in the Musical on Broadway is
slated to have a cameo as a new
character too as for the music composer
Jeff Richmond who was nominated for a
Tony Award for work on the musical
returns to craft the songs with lyrics
by n Benjamin look for Mean Girls the
musical to hit theaters on January 12th
2024 Kingsman director Matthew vaugh
returns to the world of high Espionage
in 2024 but this time with a Twist Argy
starring Henry caval centers around a
young woman named Ellie Conway played by
Bryce Dallas Howard a renowned author of
bestselling spy novels caval plays the
fictional agent Argy and sequences that
play out the events of her books as it
turns out her latest book perfectly
describes real world Espionage events
and now the villains want way more than
just her autograph the book is
phenomenal sweetie
but what happens next it's called a
cliffhanger mother ell it's called a
copout dual leipa and John Cena appear
alongside caval as part of Conway's
fictional cast well Brian Cranston plays
the movie's big bad and Katherine oara
stars as Bryce Dallas Howard's mother
Samuel L Jackson Sophia boutella Ariana
debose and Sam Rockwell fill out the
roster of stars the first trailer for
the film gives us a good idea of what to
expect from the movie it's filled with a
mix of fast-paced action explosive
stunts Ry humor and loads of SWA charm
this one will hit theaters on February
2nd 2024 before eventually heading to
Apple TV Plus in 2024 Hollywood brings
another book to the screen with it ends
with us a screen adaptation of the 2016
novel by Colleen Hoover it's a tale of
romance revolving around a young woman
named Lily who moves to a new city for
her first post colle job and is swept
off her feet by Riley but things get
complicated when an old flame of Lies
named Atlas re-enters the picture in
inspired by the real life love story of
Hoover's parents it ends with us was a
New York Times bestseller upon release
given its success a big screen version
was practically inevitable in January
2023 it was announced that former Gossip
Girl star Blake Lively had been cast in
the role of Lily while Justin baldoni
who played Raphael Solana on five
seasons of Jane the Virgin will play riy
the role of Lily's ex- lover Atlas will
be filled by Brandon scenar recently
wild audiences is Spencer Dutton on
Taylor Sheridan's 1923 its expected
release is February 9th 202 four I'm so
excited it's pretty cool to be in the
Marvel World especially with a character
that's not so known Sony's Spider-Man
universe is ready to reopen in 2024 with
the release of the weirder Wilder and
woman Centric spin-off Madam web based
on a somewhat obscure Marvel Comics
character the film will introduce
audiences to Mystical Oracle Cassandra
Webb an elderly blind Ally of the webbed
wall crawler who uses her powers of
Clairvoyance to see into his future Sony
has made some significant changes to the
character for the upcoming movie casting
30-some actor Dakota Johnson in the
title role Madame Webb will be joined by
quite a talented cast which includes
such names as celest o Conor Emma
Roberts and Adam Scott Sydney Sweeney
was recently confirmed to be playing
Julia Carpenter Marvel's second
Spiderwoman and the characters lime
action debut though little is known
about the plot at this stage Sony is
hoping for another success when it lands
in theaters on February 14th 2024
however we are expecting this movie to
be a bit different style-wise producer
Lorenzo de bonaventura told collider
that thanks to Madame Webb's psychic
abilities it's a different kind of movie
in that Universe it's almost in a way
more of a thriller when it comes to
all-time great directorial Duos few can
match the Cohen Brothers who have
created Classics that include Fargo the
big Labowski and No Country for Old Men
well the brothers next film is nowhere
to be seen Ethan Cohen was originally
set to return to theaters with a film in
2023 but the SAG after strike caused it
to be pushed back to 20124 titled
driveway dolls it's a road comedy
written by Ethan Cohen and his wife
Trisha cook and starring Margaret quali
is Jamie a Lov Loren free-spirited woman
who's just broken up with her girlfriend
with a heartache that can only be
soothed by a cross country trip she
packs her bags with her straight lace
best friend Marion played by Geraldine
viswanathan and gases up the car for a
trip to Florida during their Journey
they encounter some bumbling Crooks in
classic Cohen Brothers fashion and some
madcap hij Jinks result largely thanks
to the unexpected cargo they're carrying
in their car who are you Democrats led
by a pair of lesser known names The
Supporting Cast includes Pedro Pascal
and Matt Damon with Bill camp beanie
feldstein and Coleman Domingo it has
been pushed from its September 2023
release to February 23rd 2024 the Fall
Guy was originally a TV show that
starred lead majors in the 1980s with a
plot revolving around an action movie
stuntman who spends his spare time
working as a bounty hunter in 2024 it's
going to be a movie adaptation headlined
by Ryan Gosling and helmed by Bullet
Train director David Leech Gosling isn't
the only recognizable name in this
action future though as Emily Blunt
Stephanie Sue Winston Duke Aaron Taylor
Johnson and Hannah w inham are all set
to round round out the ensemble cast you
can also expect an appearance from Lee
Majors himself Goslin will play retired
stuntman Cole sers who spends his days
working as a Val however he's called
back to show business when his director
ex-girlfriend needs him to step in and
save for movie after the film's leading
man disappears speaking with kollider
about the movie stunts producer Kelly
McCormack assured movie goers all of the
stunts will have elements of practical
and a lot of them will be 100% practical
in fact our visual effects guys are
happy and sad that their jobs are really
marginalized on this one it just feels
like we're paying homage to the stunt
community and to really Cinema and those
of us who make the movies expect to see
the Practical action go down on March
1st 2024 the long awaited Dune sequel
Dune part two comes out 3 years after
its predecessor the cast includes
returning Stars Timothy Shalom zanda
Rebecca Ferguson Josh Brolin Dave
Bautista and Javier bardam Dune part two
adapts the rest of Herbert's
groundbreaking first novel continuing
the story of Paul a trates a young man
who seeks to bring together a group of
disparate Interstellar Empires following
the attack on his family a traes is
looking for vengeance with his ability
to see the future he knows what awaits
him and must do what he can to stop a
series of horrific events from unfolding
he who can destroy a thing has the real
control of it Den alnb returns as
director for this followup which is
scheduled to debut on March 15th 2024 a
delayed release didn't seem to affect
the first film which hauled in an
oppressive 4400 plus million and
expectations are high for the sequel the
third film meanwhile is already a strong
possibility according to VNV who says he
will adapt the second book into the
series Dune Messiah after dominating the
92nd Academy Awards bong junho returns
to both sci-fi Cinema and English
language storytelling with his 2024
directorial effort Mickey 17 based on
the book Mickey 7 by Edward Ashton the
film stars Robert patson is a clone
tasked with working on an expedition to
colonize a far off ice Planet there are
still so few details on what this
adaptation will look and feel like but
bong junho's incredible body of work
makes it impossible to not get
tantalized by this project that
excitement is bound to only increase
when one remembers the kind of cast the
director has assembled for this project
Tony kette Steven young Naomi Aki and
Mark Ruffalo are all in the supporting
lineup while Robert patson has the
film's lead role patson has always shown
a pension for working with beloved
directors and it's incredibly exciting
to imagine what he'll accomplish working
under the filmmaker responsible for
parasite needless to say there are far
more than a few or even 17 reasons to be
pumped for the release of bong Jun Ho's
Mickey 17 despite being the early wave
of postco releases Ghostbusters
afterlife was deemed arousing success
delighting audiences by by recapturing
the spirit to the original two films
this time it was a group of youngsters
battling ghosts as Trevor and Phoebe the
grandchildren of Egon Spangler were
joined by podcast and their science
teacher Mr guerson with a revive Ecto
one and the help of some old Heroes this
new generation of Ghostbusters must
confront a new threat that endangers
their small town Ghostbusters Frozen
Empire will see Gil kenon directing
while reuniting most of the first
movie's cast including Kerri kumel
nanani Patton Oswald Emily Allen Lind
and British comedian James acter have
been added to the Ensemble as as well we
also know the movie is headed back to
the Big Apple the stomping grounds of
the OG Ghostbusters who will appear in
the film push back from its original
December 20123 release the sequel is now
scheduled for March 29th
2024 I am the Dragon
Warrior get it is he the giant
dragon on March 29th 2024 po returned
for another adventure in Kung Fu Panda 4
it was revealed at cinemacon in April
2023 that Mike Mitchell of The Lego
Movie 2 the second part will direct the
animated flake bringing a new Creative
Energy to the franchise however the New
Direction won't keep people from getting
excited about all the possibilities of
seeing po go on another Epic Quest after
all the first three Kung Fu Panda movies
are among the strongest titles in the
Dreamworks Animation Cannon the film
will find po ready to become the next
ugay the spiritual leader as opposed to
the valley of Pie's martial arts master
but before he can get that promotion
he'll need to train a new Dragon Warrior
named Zen a fox who chapes underp
tutelage things get more complicated
when the villainous chameleon shows up
up a villain who somehow has the ability
to bring back old kung Fu Panda baddies
such as the scary snow leopard Ty Long
thanks to his new foe Po and Zen decided
to head to a nearby City leaving The
Valley Of Peace and getting ready for an
epic showdown it might be tough to go
bigger than the 2021 Blockbuster
crossover Godzilla versus Kong but the
sequel Godzilla X Kong the new Empire is
going to give it a shot in 2024 Godzilla
X Kong the new Empire will see The
Return of Rebecca Hall as Dr Eileen
Andrews and Brian Tyreek Henry is Bernie
Hayes while down Abby star Dan Stevens
joins the franchise in the leading role
but while the first film sees the Epic
meeting between two Titanic Terrors
Godzilla X Kong the new Empire will flip
the script following the introduction of
the hollow Earth and picking up where
the last film leaves off with Kong and
Godzilla's reluctant allies the sequel
will see the two Beast team up to take
on a new Menace that has emerged from
deep within a hidden realm audiences are
also promised a greater glimpse into the
history of these ancient monsters when
the film was released on April 12th 2024
the followup to 2023 is Rebel Moon The
scarg Giver is written and directed by
Zach Snider and it stars Jim hunu
Charlie hunam mckel hman Stars nir Ray
fiser Duna Bay Cleopatra Coleman E Duffy
and the voice of Anthony Hopkins as
mercenaries they've been enlisted by a
warrior played by Sophia bhella to fight
an evil Galactic Imperium together this
ragtag group of cosmic adventurers must
work to protect a remote Moon Under
assault from the armies of mother World
led by Regent basarios Snider has made
no secret that the pair of Rebel Moon
films were directly inspired by Kira
kurasawa 7 Samurai and that his story
was originally developed as a concept
for a Star Wars feature film when Lucas
film passed on the project Snyder and
his team took the story to Netflix
instead leading into the first film's
release the buzz around the rebel Moon
films is strong trailers already
showcase a compelling fully realized
world of cosmic conflict the sequel
Rebel Moon part two the scar Giver is
expected to hit the streaming service on
April 19th 2024 led by directors Matt
beton Ellie opin and Tyler Gillette
Indie Studio radio Silence has turned on
a few pretty impressive films this
includes ready or not scream and scream
six in 2024 they returned with an as yet
Untitled monster movie said to be in the
same vein as invisible man and Renfield
both of which were released under the
Universal Studios banner and reimagine a
classic movie monster though little is
known about the film much of the cast
has already been set the movie's roster
of talent is headlined by Melissa
Barrera of radio silence scream sequels
Katherine Newton of Ant-Man and the was
of quantum Mania and Dan Stevens of the
guest in down Abby Fame plus we can
expect to see Jean Carlo Esposito a
Breaking Bad Kevin Durand of lost Alicia
Weir of darklands William catlet of
black lightning and the late Angus cloud
of euphoria written by Guy buck and
Steven Shields the newest film from
Radio silence is scheduled to drop on
April 19th
2024 I'm taking such good care of my
little white boys originally slated for
a September 2023 release date
Challengers has been Making Waves since
its first trailer dropped in June
directed by Luca guadino the film star
Zena Is Tashi Duncan a former tennis
star whose career has been derailed due
to injury in her younger years Tashi she
was on top of the tennis world she also
participated in a three-way love affair
with a pair of pro player friends
Patrick and art who fought for her
affections on and off the court years
later Tashi is monogamously married to
Art now a grand slam champion and serves
as his coach but after art suffers a
string of losses Tashi arranges for him
to enter a so-called Challengers match
which will pit him against his old rival
friend and former Tashi coover Patrick
garnering attention Challengers could
have been one of the hottest romantic
dramas of 2023 but due to the SAG after
strike that rock Hollywood it was
shifted to the following spring
Challengers will try to overcome the
loss of its momentum when it drops into
theaters on April 26th and stands a good
chance of achieving its goal haing from
Visionary director George Miller furiosa
will serve as an action- pack prequel to
Mad Max Fury Road and will follow the
early years of the one-armed emperator
however Charlie therin won't be
returning to play her most iconic role
the movie is set over the span of 15
years so furosa will be much younger and
as Miller explained to the New York
Times he doesn't think dhing technology
is all that convincing that said the
role of Furioso has gone to none other
than the Beloved Ana Taylor Joy she'll
be joined here by Chris Hemsworth who
will be playing the film's big bad you
can also expect to see Tom Burke filling
in for Yaya Abdel matine II after the
Aquaman actor had to leave the film as
for the plot we do indeed have a
description for the film which hits
theaters on May 24th 2024 according to
the official summary we follow a young
furiosa as she survives trials war and
bloodshed trying to find her way back
home in 2024 America's favorite lasagna
loving cat as coming back to theaters
for another shot at the big screen a
fully CG animated Adventure Garfield
gets a superstar voice cast with a
famous feline himself voiced by Chris
Pratt who seems to have found a niche as
an animated voice actor his fellow MCU
star Samuel L Jackson has come on board
to provide the pipes for Garfield's
father Nicholas Holt Bing rangs Bowen
Yang sesily strong Hannah wittingham and
Brett Goldstein are also lending their
vocal talents to the film behind the
scenes it'll beat dneg handling the
animation a studio that normally
supplies First Rate CGI effects for some
of Hollywood biggest Blockbusters like
fastex and Jurassic world Dominion
Disney screenwriter David Reynolds
meanwhile is crafting the script with
Chicken Little Helmer Mark dindle
directing after securing a February
release initially the film was bumped to
May 24th 2024 once again my life has
been saved by the miracle of lasagna
Hollywood loves Planet of the Apes and
the newest attempt at the film will be
helmed by Wes ball who previously
directed The Maze Runner movies he'll be
working on a script penned by Josh
Friedman Rick Jaffa Amanda silver and
Patrick as as for the plots we know the
film will take place long after the
modern-day Apes trilogy Apes Society is
fully in control while mankind has been
reduced to animal status in this world
one ape Community has begun taking
slaves with hopes of finding human Tech
which leads a heroic ape to team up with
a human woman to keep his fellow ape
safe Owen Teague of it and I see you
will be playing the lead primate and
he'll be joined by the likes of De and
lakman Freya Allen Kevin Durand and
William H Macy we don't know who The
Supporting Cast will be playing human or
ape but we're sure that will go bananas
when Kingdom of the Planet of the Apes
hits theaters on May 24th 2024 ex set
between the third and fourth John Wick
film the second spin-off project
ballerina will star Ana de armis as a
Deadly Assassin while Kiana Reeves will
return in an extended Cameo other actors
scheduled to return in brief appearances
include Angelica Houston as the Director
Ian mcshain as Winston and Lance reck as
Chiron in one of his final performances
film not long before his death in early
2023 Norman Reus Gabriel burn and
Catalina sandino Moreno will also star
Len wisman of Total Recall Fame will be
directing ballerina and thanks to urging
from Star de armis Emerald fennel writer
director of promising young woman is
joining original screenwriter Shay
Hatton to work on the script while we
don't have an official plot synopsis we
know it will follow a female assassin
looking for revenge against those who
killed her family ballerina stands to be
another First Rate action thriller and
if the John Wick films are anything to
go by it'll certainly blow audiences
away when it releases on June 7th 2024
the Watchers is a supernatural Thriller
based on the novel by am Shine That's
already raising eyebrows thanks to its
director is Shana Shyamalan the daughter
of director Mite Shyamalan is Shana
Shyamalan cut her teeth on her father's
Apple TV plus series servant serving as
a producer while writing and directing
several episodes herself the Watchers
will be her big screen debut when it
premieres in 2024 in the novel we meet
Mina a woman who becomes lost in an
Irish Forest she joins three others who
struggle to survive while hiding in a
glass bunker and being imprisoned by
monsters in the film actress Dakota
Fanning will star as Mina while Georgina
Campbell bapa awardwin and star a
barbarian has been cast in a leading
role alongside her the Watchers has a
planned release date of June 7th 2024
and it was announced in variety that due
to its independent Financial backing the
film had received a waiver to allow it
to go before cameras in mid 2023 despite
the SAG after strike I'm too sad to walk
just give me a few hours written and
directed by Pixar veteran Pete doctor
the first Inside Out centers around a
young girl named Riley whose emotions
manifest as characters inside her head
it was a a monster hit and now it's time
for its sequel Amy perer Lewis Black and
Phyllis Smith are all set to return for
the sequel reprising the roles of Joy
anger and sadness actors Mindy Kaling
and Bill hater will not return his
disgust and fear being replaced by Lisa
leira and Tony hail there will also be a
few new characters including Rising Star
Maya Hawk is anxiety Pat doctor told
variety as for inside out a bunch more
emotions get to come in it's not just
the five we saw on the first film the
team on that one put together a really
great story that I think also has real
depth and meaning to it so fingers cross
that people like it as for the plots
polar is revealed that the film will
pick up with Riley as she deals with the
emotional changes of adolescence we'll
have to wait for June 14th 2024 to see
how it all goes down now back up Put the
gun down and give me a pack of tropical
fruit
Bubblicious and some Skittles directed
by Michael Bay and released in 1995 bad
boy starred Will Smith and Martin
Lawrence as wise cracking detectives the
sequel came 8 years later with Bay
directing again though it would take
almost two decades Smith and Lawrence
reunited for the long- awaited third
film bad boys for life in 2020 and it
was one of the last major Blockbusters
before the co9 pandemic shut down
theaters now Bad Boys is back for her
fourth film in 2024 bad boys for Life
directors Adil L ARB and bil Pala are
set to return as will Stars Will Smith
and Martin Lawrence with POA Nunes
Vanessa hudgin and Alexander Ludwig also
back from the previous film Eric danne
yoan griffi and Ria Sehorn were
announced to be joining the cast as well
the film is is expected for a June 14th
2024 release providing Some solid
counterprogramming to Pixar's Inside Out
sequel the world of a quiet place is
preparing to expand significantly with a
quiet place day one while plat details
are being kept Under Wraps we do know
that new characters will be taken center
stage with Lupita nango and Joseph Quinn
tap to play the new leads there have
also been some changes behind the scenes
with director Michael sarnoski taking
the Reigns from Jeff Nichols soski will
be working on a script he co-wrote with
Nichols which is based on a story from
producer John krinski Alex Wolf is
slated for a role in the film as well as
jimond hansu from a quiet place part two
if you're wondering how hansu will be
coming back to the franchise after his
tragic demise in the sequel film it's
because day one will be a prequel
speaking at 2023 cinemacon krinski
explained we follow Lupita and Yos
character she navigates the horrific
first moments of the alien invasion in
the loudest city of the world New York
City expect to see something truly new
and Eerie on June 28th 2024 Kevin Cosner
is returning to the big screen in 2024
with Horizon in an American Saga an
ambitious story that will be told across
four separate films Horizon will also
see cner return to the director's chair
a sprawling epic tale Horizon and
American Saga will feature a broad
ensemble cast that includes ker himself
Cenna Miller Jamie Campbell Bower
Isabelle Ferman Michael Rooker Sam
Worthington and Luke Wilson among others
it will play a wide range of characters
including pioneering settlers and Native
Americans in a story that Chronicles
according to its official synopsis The
Lure of the old west and how it was won
and lost through the blood Sweat and
Tears of many said between 1861 and 1865
the first two films in The Saga get to
the heart of the emotional and personal
drama of the American Civil War his
families and friends are torn apart the
first film is slated to be released on
June 28th 2024 while the second is
currently scheduled for just two months
later on August 16th
2024 hey Hugh you want to play Wolverine
one more
time yeah sure Ryan when Deadpool 3 was
officially announced in 2022 actor Ryan
Reynolds revealed that Hugh Jackman
would be joining him for the threequel
reprising his role as Wolverine a return
he'd previously sworn off as for the
story of Deadpool 3 we don't know much
for sure but it's likely we'll see an
epic Clash between Wade Wilson and Logan
as for the rest of the cast morina
bararan and Stefan capisic have been
confirmed to return as of several
Deadpool vets additional Supporting Cast
will include Emma Corin and Matthew
mcfan and if you're a Jennifer Garner
fan get psyched because the actress will
appear as Electra reprising the role she
first played in 2003's Daredevil the
film has a release date of July 26 2024
which was pushed back from May 2024 due
to the SAG after strike with the strike
over hopefully this will be the final
release date for Deadpool 3 what's
better than one Robert dairo in a
gangster movie two Robert dairos in a
gangster movie dairo will be playing
dual roles for 2024's alto Knights
formerly known as Wise Guys which
Chronicles the Rivalry of two real life
mafiosos in the film dairo will play
both beo geneves leader of the geneves
crime family and his Nemesis Frank
Costello head of the luchano family and
target of a assassination attempt it's
an unusual move for dairo as most movies
that feature actors in more than one
role typically have their star playing
related characters can director Barry
levenson pulloff having such a
well-known and recognizable actor
playing the two biggest characters in a
dramatic True Crime biopic only time
will tell but the film is being penned
by Good Fellas and casino scribe
Nicholas py and will have a Supporting
Cast that includes Deborah Messing
Katherine Narducci and Cosmo Jarvis the
film is due for release on November 15th